the centers for disease control is
pointing to three new studies to
underscore its case that covert 19
vaccines are standing up to the highly
infectious omicron variant the agency
says this is especially true among
people who receive booster shots they
tend to be better protected from severe
disease hospitalization and death the
average number of new coveted cases is
down 9
from this time last week and as the
anticipation builds for the approval of
a vaccine for young children michael
george is here with the latest michael
good morning jeff good morning it's hard
to believe it but this week marks two
years since covid was first detected in
the u.s and while there are some
encouraging signs that omicron has
peaked in some parts of the country
there's also a troubling rise in the
number of kids being infected
more and more children are being brought
to hospitals and pediatricians offices
sick with covid can you show me in
georgia dr matthew wilson says the
holidays and the return to school are
fueling cases erasing the progress made
in the fall
at that time we were only having about a
three percent positive testing rate for
covid
and then
once the omicron variant hit now we're
somewhere between 20 and 30 percent
positivity
schools have been forced to close in
parts of new jersey
some texas parents have been asked to
fill in as substitute teachers
we have a lot of teachers and
administrators out because they're
covered either because they have tested
positive and kansas city's children's
mercy hospital set a record with 32
hospitalized children 14 of them are
under the age of two and three are in
the icu
it's sad
it you know it's so unnecessary many are
unvaccinated of course not yet eligible
to get a shot vaccines and boosters
are more important than ever in our
fight against omicron in california
legislation introduced thursday would
allow children as young as 12 to get an
fda approved vaccine without a parent's
consent because of how many people we've
gotten vaccinated the country is in a
much stronger position to face omicron
and to deal with covet going forward at
the white house hopeful signs in the
fight against omicron were reported
friday we are starting to see steep
declines in areas that were first
peaking so areas of the northeast new
york rhode island connecticut are really
starting to come down that also means
that some areas are higher than they had
been before but overall nationally the
case numbers are coming down which i
consider an optimistic trend
but health officials caution we're not
out of the woods yet they say more than
2 000 americans are still dying every
day from covid so mask mandates are
still necessary jeff michael thank you